so i have a problem whitney can you help
me with this yes this is whitney you
this
i i couldn't even look him in the face
when this happened so yeah she's the
right person for this okay so
last week
we sat down after one of our podcasts
and we decided let's reach out to comics
we haven't had or performers that could
be guests
on tiger belly so what i did is i went
to my phone my contacts
i think we're listening to the neil one
um
neil brennan which i love by the way um
it is weird because you like
don't want to ask people to be on your
podcast because it's like you're like
but
so many people ask we don't normally
have to ask
right
am i making any sense no i don't get
well just when neil was like how come
you haven't asked me to be on i i would
shoot myself in the head before i'd ask
neil to be on my podcast yeah you know
what i mean but then you're like well
why wouldn't you ask me and i'm like why
haven't you asked me it's just like
there's no like co there's no consistent
procedure yet beyond that this
is beyond that nightmare so i went
through my whole fight and i was you
know it's there's some names in here i
was like you know what they're gonna say
no but i'm gonna reach out anyway right
new bob new bob new bob is like a
self-worth yeah and so bobby lee so i
you know i and people that said no in
the past i reached out to like sebastian
manosko and he's he wants to do it now
we're fine enough trying to find a date
there's other ones so i went down and i
got down to the tease
right titus and i saw daniel tosh
oh yeah in my phone
under detox such a [ __ ] masochist oh
my god okay all right so i go
hey it's bobby lee this probably isn't
your number anymore but can you do my
podcast please i love you
that's what i said
he responds right away
because bobby i would love to brother
here send your pho have your folks send
me the details
and he's like thank god i didn't change
my number
right so sweet sweet lovely so i go
thanks dude exclamation goes he goes of
course i'm honored and i almost cried
i'm like oh my god this guy's that's
something that's going on yeah see a
scientologist now what happened yes so
the next day um
it says bobby your podcast today i'm so
sorry about you and kalyala he goes all
into it
and then he goes let's get then this is
where it gets fishy he goes let's get
together this weekend i'll be in la it'd
be great to catch up love you man
so i'm like wow he's religious or i
don't know
i'm around it's been tough
let's get coffee or something let me
know
then he responds right away straight
say strong brother
and then this and that
and then
i look up at you know i i don't have his
fa picture saved but i looked up into
this photo right here oh my god and it
says tosh
i don't know what that means so i google
tash
and it's the same indian guy
wait i didn't even know this i told you
whitney
sit down sit down please please please
i had such second-hand embarrassment
over here
wait who is this guy right right i don't
know
so
a diverse person
yes
right so i saved dan d taj and i put i
should have put tash as the anyway it's
okay i i i saved it as death
so then i go
then i go hey tash i thought i was
texting with daniel tosh the comedian
sorry for the miscommunication
misunderstanding ha ha i'm so sorry and
then he goes
the fact that tash
sent you to his people
is the craziest part
who is he exactly well you know he's i
looked him up he is the ceo of this
company it's like a tech company like he
doesn't have people why is he in your
phone but this is how i change because
in the past i would have gone i'm just
going to have to have them on my podcast
the fact that
some random guy on our podcast just
because i [ __ ] up on the whole thing
tosh
yeah he's the founder of char
um we gotta have him on the fact i think
we have to have
he i'm sure this happens anyone that has
a name similar to a famous person it
happens all the time but they don't have
a similar name
daniel tosh
yeah that's his first name if a comedian
is re that is not known for having
all you know right the cards in the deck
text you about
the podcast he should have deduced like
oh he's probably talking about daniel
tosh right but this is how dumb i am
and how i don't read things so the
initial his initial response was love to
brother have your folks send me the
details
i already knew it wasn't tasha when he
was like i listened to your episode of
tiger i i i know sorry about your
breakup he goes miss you so much vixx
and i got to see you at the comedy club
a few weeks ago you should in my head
i'm like who's vic
i don't know vixx all right because i
know
can you imagine tosh watching a comedy i
know and and he would have called it the
store not comedy club
i mean there's so many socks
but in my head and he's like i saw your
skit down at the comedy club you're like
yeah yeah so i
not only did i not not [ __ ] you man [ __ ]
you when he came home and told me this
story i was like get out of my face yeah
yeah yeah yeah remember i called you and
i go i called him i go don't
i call them i go don't email the guy
i was so disappointed with so many
friends we're gonna finally get daniel
tasha
for like five years have you ever had
tasha's no i don't even have his [ __ ]
number you have his can we facetime him
no no don't face time now i'm so
embarrassed please don't not right now
well you just don't respond it'll go
away you just have to not respond no i
already did i i said i mean he's he at
the end i apologize and at the end he
goes it's all good yeah it would be the
first cheers
but now i have to get tosh on here
just
for like at least 15 minutes and go i'm
so sorry yeah that'd be funny
what it
i feel like we've milked that for all it
was worth i feel like that was the
perfect ending story and it's over yeah
yeah uh i feel like anyway so
do you think i handled it well
not particularly
but yeah that's just a nightmare but the
bigger question is um
uh tash has he ever done a podcast i'm
sure that's why i thought
oh my god he doesn't do all the other
ones right so i'm like
this is going to be great for me it was
worse for me because when he said
kalylah sorry about